Fox News Alert now on progress of the
COBIT 19 vaccine front as biotech
company moderna reports very positive
results from an early human trial which
did show that people given its potential
vaccine generated antibodies to the
virus joining us now is Alexei czar
Health and Human Services Secretary you
read through the details that moderna
has released its stock is skyrocketing
17% today mr. secretary and welcome
markets are up anticipation of this as
well how confident are you that this
could be the game changer that could
lead us to a vaccine by end of year well
president Trump is leading operation
warp-speed which is gonna put bets on
several vaccines this one the Moderne
vaccine was actually invented here at
NIH and within eight weeks we brought
that to clinical trials it's really
historic as you said some very promising
data showing the vaccine provokes what
are called neutralizing antibodies that
attack the virus and so just really
important advance and we're gonna be
putting other big bets on other vaccines
so we're so we're not going to butt into
battle with just one shot mr. secretary
talk about next steps there in maybe
kind of a multi-pronged approach here
because while you've got operation warp
speed on the vaccines you've all you
also have States reopening pieces of
their economy our own PT XF has been in
a gym in New Jersey to give you one
quick example and initially the police
we're standing outside and we're maybe
going to shut this gym down and he's now
reporting that in fact they went inside
saw that people were social distancing
and despite the governor's lockdown
orders they're gonna let this gym move
forward talk about what you're seeing in
terms of balancing reopening the economy
and making sure people are safe yeah I'm
glad you asked about that because so
often we're describing this as a
conflict between health versus the
economy I see this as really health vs.
health there are very serious health
consequences from being locked down for
extended periods we've seen reductions
in cardiovascular procedures we've seen
increases in suicide risk we've seen
reductions in cancer screenings and
pediatric vaccinations these are real
and significant health consequences and
we've got to balance that against the
health benefit of stay at home and we
believe thanks to the president
historic response that we can get back
to work and back to school with
appropriate mitigating steps to resume
our lives and resume the great and
important work of our economy what what
evidence have you seen so far that the
reopening of some areas of our country
is going well as you have previously
said is it too early to tell her is
there conclusive evidence that things
are looking up no it's the right
question I'd say it's still too early to
tell in terms of data so we've got
states like Texas and Georgia which are
reopening Florida which did not do as
severe of a lockdown where we the data
trends seemed to be good with the
exception of certain concentrated
outbreaks like meat packing facilities
but it's still too early to tell we'll
watch that data and I think it's one of
the brilliant parts of the president's
strategy here of respecting federalism
you'll have a diversity of approaches
and states and that will really be a
laboratory for us to see what works and
what doesn't work it'll be very
important but will will be cautious and
appropriate but we've got to work to get
this country back to work mr. secretary
there are pieces where you can let the
state go forward and take a leave there
are other parts where maybe the federal
government has to step in for example
where we see this syndrome in children
particularly in New York but maybe other
parts of the country there's one ninth
grader saying that it felt like someone
injected straight-up fire into their
body and people doctors at this hour are
trying to figure out it was it related
to kovat what's happening what does the
federal government know about this
syndrome and what are you doing to make
sure our kids are safe yeah so it is
fortunately a very rare syndrome it's
related it's comparable to what we call
Kawasaki syndrome it's an inflammatory
response essentially your body is
getting provoked by this foreign body
the virus that's in it and it and our
immune system creates this inflammatory
response and this is a rare outbreak but
we are working across the world with our
colleagues and other health ministries
to gather data on this to study to see
what do we know what are the best
treatments for this and how do we help
these kids who get it considering that
in considering dr. fauci's words about
how we have to be so careful with how
this virus behaves it in particular
behaves in children still we don't don't
know a lot how hopeful are you that kids
will be able to go back to school in the
fall mr. secretary
well we'll have to see how the disease
progresses over the summer
but I'm quite hopeful I think we need to
get back to school we need we there are
ways that we can we can bring back our
economy and bring back our lives in
smart sensible wases take schools for
the example that you raise
maybe we minimize auditoriums and big
public big gatherings at our schools and
maybe we arrange our seating in
classrooms appropriately but there there
are ways that we can take that are short
of locking ourselves in our homes that
allow us to function and get back closer
to normal as we progress even as under
the president's direction with operation
warp speed we bring therapies to market
we bring vaccines to market and of
course we have the the world's best
testing system now in place mr.
secretary earlier today you spoke
virtually to the World Health Assembly a
World Health Organization at the center
of that obviously and you said today one
member state you didn't name them tried
to conceal this outbreak I think
everyone pretty much knows you were
pointing the finger at China please
expand upon that and let us know as well
the president has threatened to cut off
funding to the World Health Organization
in part because they helped cover China
cover all of this up at the beginning is
the president going to cut off funding
to the whu-oh or not well I'm not going
to get ahead of the president making a
denounce but I'm going to tell you I
delivered at the President's request an
extremely stern warning and message to
the World Health Organization today
which is that they're in need of
significant structural reform they've
got to be held accountable there needs
to be an independent investigation of
them but their conduct towards China
here and China's conduct has got to be
on the table you know China concealed
information about human to human
transmission they did not reveal the
asymptomatic transmission of this
disease and for a month and a half while
I personally fought to get CDC and World
Health Organization people into China to
learn this kind of evidence they
resisted for an entire month and a half
precious time was lost when the world
community could have been learning and
China concealed and concealed viral
isolates and other evidence that we
needed to be
able to treat people and prevent the
spread of this disease and they they
shut their own city down
cities down while having people continue
to fly around the world seeding the rest
of the world with the virus
mr. secretary finally when it comes to
finger-pointing obviously we're looking
at China and what happened there but
here at home the president's own
economic adviser Peter Navarro has gone
on the record pointing fingers at the
CDC for early on what he referred to as
bad testing he said it quote set us back
how do you respond to that this morning
well the the comments regarding CDC are
inaccurate and inappropriate the the CDC
had had one error which was in scaling
up the manufacturing of the tests that
they had developed there was a
contamination that didn't affect the
accuracy of the test just led to two
inconclusive results they fixed that
within weeks and got it out that was
never going to be the backbone of
testing in the u.s. that's that's low
throughput public health lab testing
what we need is the private sector to
develop the test the abbot's the Roches
the thermo Fisher's get them in the
market get those high throughput tests
that now the president is delivering
300,000 tests per day over ten million
tests 12.9 million will be done in the
justjust the next several weeks that's
the private sector brings that to bear
that's not the CDC that's really
leveraging this whole of government
approach that the president has
marshaled here okay Alex azar the
Secretary of Health and Human Services
we appreciate coming on today thank you
sir thank you thank you